mike pompéo est arrivé vendredi à paris
pour une visite de trois jours au goût
d'adieu mais la capitale française
semble avoir déjà tourné la page trumps
mike on pe rencontrera son homologue
français jean yves le drian puis
emmanuel macron ce lundi matin
au menu des discussions le terrorisme de
confier au haut karabagh de quoi montrer
à l'allié français que l'administration
trent tient toujours les rênes à
washington mike pompéo refusant lui
aussi de reconnaître la défaite du
candidat républicain
il y aura une transition en douceur vers
une deuxième administration trump
absolument nous sommes prêts le monde
regarde ce qui se passe nous allons
compter tous les votes lorsque le
processus sera terminé il y aura de
grands électeurs sélectionné c'est tout
un processus
la constitution le détail assez
clairement l'elysée de son côté est déjà
en contact avec la nouvelle équipe
supposée arrivée à la maison blanche
emmanuel macron a reconnu la victoire de
joe biden del annonce des résultats et
s'est entretenu mardi avec lui pour la
première fois joe biden a promis de
redynamiser les relations avec l'otan et
l'union européenne malmenée par donald
trump
le président français l'a assuré de sa
volonté de travailler ensemble sur le
climat la santé et la lutte
antiterroriste auparavant sur fox news
mike pompéo n'avait pas manqué de
critiquer ces appels jugée précipitée
des dirigeants étrangers à joe biden et
il est inapproprié pour ses dirigeants
étrangers de contact et joe biden si
c'est juste pour dire bonjour j'imagine
que c'est pas trop problématique mais
que l'on ne s'y trompe pas il n'y a
qu'un président à la fois qu'un seul
secrétaire d'état et une seule équipe de
sécurité nationale après la france mike
pompéo doit se rendre en turquie en
géorgie en israël et dans trois pays du
golfe
une tournée diplomatique avec un
objectif préserver l'écho de la voie
diplomatique de donald trump sur la
scène internationale
au moins jusqu'au 20 janvier 2021